In our solution, we always compute the
t and x and v value at the beginning of the next step,
and you make use of the fact that the entry number
0 of t and the entry number 0 of x and the entry number 0 of v
are already equal to 0, which is what we want.
If you run the program, you see that per second,
the velocity decreases by 10 m/s.
It starts out at 0 and keeps decreasing,
which means the speed, the magnitude
of the velocity keeps increasing.
This falling object gets faster and faster,
but in a negative direction, which is our x coordinate
starts at 0 as intended.
It decreases slowly
and then faster and faster.
You see gravitational acceleration in action.